بعد 20 عامًا من تحطم الإرهابيين بطائرات
في البرجين التوأمين لمركز التجارة العالمي
، الرجل الذي ساعد في تسجيل وصول
بعض المهاجمين في مطار في ماين
يفكر الآن
في ذلك الصباح
كان مايك توي وكيل تذاكر في مطار
بورتلاند الدولي حيث كان اثنان من
الإرهابيين  في وقت لاحق ، طاروا طائرة إلى
البرج الشمالي ، واستقلوا أول
رحلة لهم في ذلك اليوم المشؤوم
، ولم يفعلوا أي شيء
لإثارة أي شكوك حقيقية
أنهم ربما
مارسوها مرات لا تحصى في مطارات مختلفة ،
وكان هذا هو
السؤال المؤلم الذي ظل يدور في
ذهني لسنوات  أنني ذهبت إلى الاستشارة
بسبب
ما فاتني ،
لماذا لم أر هذا
الذي سمعته هناك ، فقد مر سنوات
من تقديم المشورة ، وهو الآن متقاعد في
صناعة الطيران ويقول إنه تعلم
ألا يلوم نفسه على هذا
الهجوم المميت ونحن بالتأكيد  أتمنى
أن يكون هذا شيئًا يجب التصالح معه
على أي حال